comment allez vous la prochaine fois que
j'avais dès demain c'est à will poole
moi ça va
aujourd'hui on va parler des croisières
cette vidéo elle fait partie de superbus
vidéo où j'ai découvert un game et j'ai
envie d'en parler avec vous en 2019 pour
la première fois de ma vie j'ai vu un
navire de croisière à un port c'est
diabolique hockey diabolique et en
passant devant je me suis dit mais qui
fait ça qui fait des croisières comme ça
alors j'ai cherché sur internet et la
réponse et 28 millions personnes en 2019
c'est beau ou pas donc mon petit ou au
teint de merde là ce qui fait ça va
c'est terminé je referai plus les
rockets ce qui me fascine avec cette
histoire des croisières c'est qu'à un
moment donné dans l'histoire de
l'humanité il ya un mec qui s'est dit
les immeubles c'est bien mais les
immeubles sur l'eau qui bouge c'est
mieux donc je vais en faire moi perso
j'ai aucun potes autour de moi ga la
vingtaine ou la trentaine et qui a fait
des croisières genre ça n'existe pas
c'est une ou deux générations au dessus
de nous pousse à qui veut bien les
croisières mais nous pas trop notre
délire ne sait plus sur une plage juste
une plage avec un chien alors une
croisière c'est quoi cette question elle
n'est pas évidente parce que pour moi
une croisière c'était aller sur les
quais de seine avec sa grand-mère et
emprunté un bateau mouche pour deux
heures le plaisir d'avancé sur la seine
entre les riffs parisienne je les fais
une fois et en passant sous un pont mon
grand père s'est fait chier dessus par
un pigeon j'ai ri aux larmes
moi je pensais que les croisières
c'était ça pas du tout les croisières cd
bateau parfois de plusieurs centaines de
mètres de long capable d'accueillir des
milliers de personnes de partir au large
pendant des semaines de s'arrêter dans
plein de port pour visiter la ville
avant de repartir
n'étant jamais allé sur un de ses
bateaux je me suis dit mais il ya quoi
sur un bateau comme ça jusqu'où ils sont
allés et ben écoute ils sont allés bien
au-delà de ce que j'imaginais
j'ai découvert le seven 6 explorer il
s'agit de la croisière la plus luxueuse
du monde
globalement sur ce bateau il ya tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer piscines dont
une à débordement moi j'aimerais faire
du golf sur mon bateau bon bah ça c'est
totalement possible qu'ils en tirent un
golf sur ceux plus tôt mme batho pareil
pour le tennis fait vos meilleurs
échanges au milieu de l'océan
sur les murs il ya de véritables
tableaux de picasso ya un théâtre un
solarium
il ya et ça c'est pas plus grand bateau
c'est le plus luxueux
le plus grand c'est le symphony of the
six il fait 362 m de long et 66 mètres
de large et il peut accueillir jusqu'à
six mille six cents passagers et 2300
membres d'équipage et combien de tonnes
il pèse à votre avis ce chiffre c'est le
plus d'1 2 128 mille tonnes c'est bon il
est tellement grand il savait plus quoi
faire ils ont fait une tyrolienne sur le
bateau de 24 mais il ya aussi deux murs
d'escaladé de simulateur de surf choix
pourquoi et un total de 23 restaurants
vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai dit
démoniaque c'est démoniaque un truc pas
non mais vraiment c'est impressionnant
évidemment il ya un mais c'est que ça
pollue énormément
en gros ces bateaux là les utilisent du
fioul lourd c'est un pétrole quasi brut
et qui coûte beaucoup moins cher et
surtout qui n'est soumis à aucune taxe
aux sa relève énormément d'oxydé de
soufre ha bref je fais le petit point
aux pollutions quand même pour pas trop
donner envie aux gens de faire des
croisières bref maintenant j'aimerais me
raconter trois histoires qui ont eu lieu
sur des croisés la première c'est arrivé
à plein de navires c'est la chiasse je
te jure en fait il ya eu plein de cas
d'épidémie de gastro sur des navires
sauf que du coup ça se répand d'une
manière folle
à tel point que le bateau dans certains
cas a dû faire deux petites tellement
c'était invivable pour les passagers et
surtout c'était dangereux parce que
l'infection se répandait vraiment vite
et en fait à partir du moment où deux
pour cent des membres d'un bateau tombe
malade bas le bateau est obligé de le
déclarer et du coup les pays refusent
l'arrivée du bateau au port donc le
bateau vous retourne à sa destination
initiale pour maintenant quelques au but
ça nous choque pas et on se dit bao est
plutôt logique ça fait énormément
d'humains au même endroit bon c'est
normal mais je pense qu'elle est forte
quand les mecs se sont rangés les
épidémies sur un bateau et s'y attendait
pas du tout tu repars avec tâche ya
cette ut est d'ailleurs juste avant que
le kobe d'explo je me souviens que
j'étais au japon et un bateau de
croisière qui devait arriver au japon il
ya eu des quatre co vite dessus et le
japon a refusé l'amarrage du bateau et
donc il a dû rester éloigné des côtes
deuxième truc
les tempêtes vous avez vu les tempêtes
des fois que les bateaux il se manche y
avait des vidéos sur youtube de bateaux
de pêche qui sont des gros bateaux ans
qui se retrouve en pleine tempête je
sais pas trop comment et les flots se
déchaînent autour d'eux on dirait un
film d'horreur je vous jure si ça
m'arrivait je serai traumatisés à vie je
n'arrivais même plus à prendre un bain
ça me rappellerait la tempête mais qu'à
écouter c'est arrivé récemment en 2017
il ya un bateau de croisière qui s'est
retrouvé au milieu
une méga tempête les passagers bien
entendu ont filmé tout ce qui se passait
donc on a plein de l'image de ça et
c'est méga impressionnant en gros le
bateau il était arrêté aux bahamas et
plein d'experts en météo prévoyait
l'arrivée d'une méga tempête d'une bombe
météorologique on appelle ça du nom de
grace et on sait pas pourquoi mais la
compagnie de croisière et le capitaine
plutôt que d'attendre que la tempête
passe ils ont voulu doubler la tempête
ils ont voulu traverser avant qu'il
attend peine pire cole le bateau et
s'est retrouvé au milieu d'une tempête
de légende avec des vagues de neuf
mètres qui tapait quand la coque du
bateau et du coup il ya de l'eau qui
s'est infiltrée partout
le bateau il était penché donc quand les
gens marcher dans les couloirs fin
c'était on aurait vraiment dit
franchement une scène du film titanic
qu'en externe etc on connaît la suite
donc je comprends qu'ils aient eu très
peur ses passagers et en fait ce qui est
horrible c'est que le capitaine il a
rien dit il a juste dit c'est tout et la
sq et où c'est que c'est pas comme quand
un avion ou des turbulences elles vont
durer une heure ou deux heures le navire
il a été pris dans la tempête pendant
trois jours c'est super l'autre watch
pendant trois jours il ya de l'eau qui
tombe du plafond frérot était là genre
mais je parle anglais puisque c'est
essentiellement des américains qui font
des croisières plus de peur que de mal
tout le monde est arrivé sain et sauf y
ait eu aucun blessé aucun mort n'a rien
du tout c'était juste trois jours de
peur de frayeur de fou mais le bateau a
tenu le coup le capitaine a tenu le cap
et tout le monde va bien maintenant la
troisième histoire peut-être certains
d'entre vous la connaissez l'histoire du
titanic énorme blague des abonnés vous
je vais vous parler de l'oceane hausse
un bateau construit en face le béret et
la baguette ce paquebot il a été vendu
ou loué plusieurs fois il a été mis pour
la première fois à l'eau en juillet 1952
donc c'est un bon moment en soixante dix
il est racheté devient le mit qui n'a
hélas il vient juste un ferry entre la
pire et la crète en 72 pareil ils
changent de fonction il fait des trajets
entre en connaît pas trace et tout ça
nous amène en 88 ou l'oceane hausse est
affrété pour une durée de huit mois par
la compagnie tfc tour franchement il
n'est pas en état de dengue le bateau il
a beaucoup changé de mains mais ya très
peu de mains qui sont dits ou l'apa ou
l'état du bateau j'ai mettre de l'argent
pour réparer tout ça il ya des parties
de coqs détacher les clapets antiretour
sont démontés c'est à dire que dans le
chemin des eaux usées à tout moment les
eaux usées peuvent remonter et surtout
et ça c'est incroyable
il ya un trou de 10 cm dans une cloison
et torches qui donc ne l'est plus du
tout est en fait pourquoi il ya ce trou
c'est parce qu'à un moment il tentait de
faire un peu de maintenance sur le
bateau et devait mettre un système de
ventilation sauf qu'ils n'ont pas fait
et ils ont tellement pas fait qu'ils ont
même pas reboucher le trou campagne et
c'est ça moi qui me fait trop peur
prendre l'avion ou un ferry ou faire une
attraction la fête foraine j'ai trop
peur qui est des soucis mécaniques et
que les mecs n'ai pas vu ses soucis mais
bon le 3 août 91 malgré tous ces
problèmes techniques la météo est
dégueulasse mais le capitaine décide
quand même de quitter island donne en
afrique du sud pour rejoindre durban le
bateau part et là il ya une petite
tradition c'est de faire une grande fête
sur le pont sauf que comme la météo est
dégueulasse ça se passe à la place à
l'intérieur du bateau dans le salon four
seasons et liam hausses et treize civils
deux artistes en vogue à l'époque qui
doivent jouer de la musique et ils ont
leur importance et passe pas une méga
bonne soirée puisque les passagers s'en
bat les couilles de la fête de départ et
rs dans l'argent après quelques heures
tout le monde entend une grosse
explosion dans le bateau cette explosion
elle est causée par une fuite dans la
salle des machines l'eau entre par la
coque du coup les générateurs sont
coupés pour éviter tout court circuit et
le navire est donc plongé dans le noir
avec plus aucune énergie l'eau dans la
salle des machines continuer de monter
elle va atteindre le fameux trou de dix
centimètres qu'il ya dans la paroi
étanche trou qui mène à la caisse à au
noir c'est à dire toutes les eaux
usagées du bateau quand tu tire la
chasse d'eau quand tu te lave les mains
bref tout le vous avez compris mais
souvenez-vous les clappes et retours ne
sont plus là il ya donc plus de
protection dans aucune canalisations et
les passagers du bateau vont vivre un
grand moment puisque toutes les eaux
usagées vont remonter dans leurs lavabo
dans leurs douze dans leurs toilettes
à partir de là on est sur une croisière
agréable l'ambiance est pas mal
l'équipage réalise que dans quelques
heures le navire va couler et met en
place du coup de protocole d'urgence qui
vise à rassembler les gens et à les
mettre en sécurité avant que ça coule
sur batterie qu ils préviennent aucun
passager ils font pas du tout la
procédure d'urgence donc les passagers
ils ont aucune idée de ce qui se passe
le temps passe et plus la dans les
couloirs et commence à y avoir un peu
d'eau les passagers sont pas dieu ils
ont pas encore vu le film titanic parce
qu'il n'est pas encore sorti mais ils
connaissent la célèbre histoire du
titanic qui comprennent donc que quelque
chose ne va pas du tout avec le navire
et de fil en aiguille ils s'aperçoivent
que la majorité de l'équipage et le
capitaine havre anas sont déjà équipés
et prêts à évacuer dans un canot de
sauvetage
absolument pas concerné par la sécurité
leurs passagers s'en bat les couilles et
c'est là que mot 6 le musicien que
personne n'avait écouté joué en début de
soirée va se charger personnellement
d'envoyer un sos à tous les bateaux un
loto ce signal heureusement va être
captée par pas mal de navires qui était
pas loin et qui se rendent à proximité
du bateau pour aider tous les passagers
à l'évacuer l'opération de sauvetage
elle va durer sept heures et elle va et
rythme et surtout par des allers retours
seize hélicoptères entre le bateau et la
terre ferme et c'est une opération de
sauvetage incroyable puisque sur 571
passagers 571 ont été sauvés pour la
majorité des passagers
moïse et le grand héros de cet événement
cellule ranque a pris les choses en main
et qui a permis le sauvetage de tout le
monde et ce sacré beau gosse ne s'arrête
pas là puisque la légende raconte même
que c'est lui et sa femme tracey hills
qui ont quitté le bateau en dernier
waouh huit heures après le début de
l'incident l'oceane au school à 92
mètres de profondeur mais attendez il ya
quelqu'un dans la sauce là le capitaine
mon frérot yanis havre anas et la 560 kg
ce témoin de ce qu'il a fait il va être
accusé d'avoir laissé tout le monde à
l'abandon ménagères yanis à une défense
très solide il va déclarer avoir dû
quitter le navire pour organiser au plus
vite les opérations de sauvetage
why année quel culot il a même déclaré
lorsque je donne l'ordre d'abandon du
navire ça n'a pas d'importance à quel
moment je quitte le navire l'ordre
d'abandon et pour tout le monde
si certains veulent rester ils peuvent
rester retirer lui sont permis bateau
vous me le dégager celui-là bref vous
connaissez le titanic maintenant vous
connaissez l'oceane hausse qui aime bien
plus cool histoire puisque personne
n'est décédé
contrairement à jack
si la planche avait été un peu plus
grande bah écoutez c'est la fin de cette
vidéo je pensais pas un jour qu'on
parlerait de croisière rossa devient
qu'est-ce que ça devient la chaîne là
mais j'ai découvert tout ça je voulais
trop en parler avec vous sur ya plein de
gens qui connaissaient pas ce game des
croisières gigantesque des incidents qui
a eu et ou peut-être que je lis dans une
grotte et que j'étais le seul appât et
au courant quai des croisières des
navires aussi gigantesque mais je trouve
ça vraiment impressionnant je séméga
boîtes de conserve sur lesquels il ya
plus de trucs cool que dans sa propre
ville c'est c'est tellement insolent
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plus que ce
petit format vous plaît voilà si je
découvre d'autres games et où j'en parle
avec j'aimerais ça me fait plaisir d'en
parler avec vous de partager mon
étonnement je vous dis au plaisir
j'espère que vous avez bien choper tous
vos cadeaux de noël
moi non c'est pas si drôle
[Musique]